oh no you know I had to do this one
because y'all said it to me unlike the
the racist night of Los Angeles don't do
any racial [ __ ] around me Oh what is
going on YouTube now if you guys haven't
heard of this story well this one's a
doozy and it's also because UCLA's
probably too busy trying to cover it up
but that's why you have people like me
to uncover it up that wasn't it's
[ __ ] [ __ ] but as you guys already
know that if you send me multiple
articles you already know that I'm gonna
have to get in on this one
UCLA is very old and Sigma Phi Epsilon
decided to go ahead and throw a Kanye
West themed party now that in and of
itself seems pretty innocent right but
that's only if we give these people the
benefit of the doubt and of course if we
did this wouldn't be much of an article
still no it [ __ ] up the kanye western
party was filled with a bunch of white
people doing blackface ah
y'all just found out I don't wear pants
when I do this and no contrary to
popular racist belief it was just
charcoal to represent a Western thing
damn [ __ ] really is that actually the
best excuse that you have not allow you
to make it up [ __ ] on the spot
that's like you getting caught cheating
on the spot and then saying maybe I'll
just rip and fell on the [ __ ] uh I was
yawning and then like the dick just went
right and no [ __ ] you do not black out
your whole face unless number one you
are doing blackface or number two you
lived in a mineshaft your whole life act
like you wanted the chimney sweepers and
Mary Poppins [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of
here I think one of my biggest pet
peeves is when someone who is so openly
racist gets confronted of their racism
they had like that I'm not what's going
on I now are you telling me that in the
whole group of people there wasn't at
least one person thinking hey guys I
think if we black out our faces we're
for elephant in favor of black people
they might think it's racist really you
go to UCLA a place of higher learning
and not a one person thought that this
just might be a bad idea and just to put
this out there contrary to popular white
belief well I saw black person do white
face and everybody thinks just hilarious
such hypocrite okay well let me just go
ahead and break this
for a few of you misguided white people
out there that think that this is a
legitimate excuse for what you're doing
you are an idiot
there is no complaint protests or civil
outrage when people do white face
because there is no institutional racism
against white people in this country
there is no such thing as black
privilege there is no such thing as
Asian privilege there is no such thing
as Mexican privilege
that's like saying purfles black people
go with their black supremacy oh my god
that doesn't exist so yes when you paint
your [ __ ] face black you sag your
pants with gold chains and grills in
your [ __ ] mouth you are mocking a
culture summing up that that is their
whole identity look at me I'm doing my
face hahahaha I might privilege and I'm
successful and I know I get it you hate
constantly hearing the phrase white
privilege well guess what just because
you hate here yet doesn't mean that it
doesn't exist and you know why you don't
think it exists is because you are white
and you are the one experiencing the
white privilege and mind you yes there
are a few degenerates out there that
will use white privilege as a way to
victimize themselves but that is the
small cluster and it doesn't take away
from the fact that yes it does exist
white privilege is real and systemic
racism in America exists and I want you
to think about this for a second if it
really was in blackface and all those
costumes were completely harmless why
would a few protestors outside really
bother everybody enough to go ahead and
leave the party or why would the
students in blackface when they saw
another black student would see it and
they would try to walk the other way
oh and if they were so in the right why
would they wait for the protesters to
leave so they could hide their faces and
then sneak right back into the party you
know why cuz it sounds like you're
[ __ ] up you know every time a group of
white people does something crazy racist
I just want there to be a theme song
that's why folks you know what the sad
thing is and I have
multiple times before that when you walk
into an institution of higher learning
you would expect better but you know why
that's not the case because small groups
such as fraternities sororities and even
certain clubs go ahead and make a
mockery of other people's cultures and
it's okay because it's constantly
brushed off as a [ __ ] joke these
schools also don't take the [ __ ]
initiative to point out these
[ __ ] and tell them how [ __ ]
wrong and irresponsible it is but
instead we'll go ahead and like to put
it under another rules as you know who
knows people who condone this [ __ ] start
this party and even [ __ ] attended it
should know that it was racist and the
fact is that you do but you don't give a
[ __ ] about the consequences because you
think everybody else is tripping
everybody else is being dumb and
sensitive because it is not a part of
your [ __ ] culture but as I start to
calm down from the [ __ ] I want to give
people the benefit of the [ __ ] doubt
let's just say at the best scenario
possible they just wanted to mock Kanye
West and Kim Kardashian and in no way
they thought that anybody would perceive
this as racist then by us having to give
you the benefit of the doubt we now have
to assume that you are stupid as [ __ ]
you are by far the dumbest [ __ ]
on earth and we fail to understand how
you got into UCLA you are [ __ ] idiots
so you really only have two options
you're either really racist or you're
[ __ ] stupid as [ __ ] and it's so funny
when I read other articles actually
defending the party it's not as races as
the other party and of course the people
who wanted to defend the party only
posted pictures of people with the
mildly racist costumes a little bit of
Kim Kardashian here they use a little
bit of Kanye West's lurex here and there
but you forgot to add the pictures of
the blackface people huh
what about those where are thousands and
you know what the racism part isn't the
part that bothers me is the fact that
there was a group of kids in UCLA LA
about these one of the most culturally
diverse places on this earth where they
literally thought it was okay you know
I'm just gonna say this man in the most
nicest way possible if I ever see you
guys do that again I'm going to hire a
rhino to stomp on your [ __ ] testicles
and a tiger to rip off the nipples on
your tiny little breasts and no I don't
have that type of money
unless this you know video gets like 14
million views the Jose Oh shits gonna
happen [ __ ] what did I get this purple
shirt hey what is going on YouTube thank
you guys for watching that video and yes
that was an article submitted by you now
if you guys want to be a part of my
videos and you want to submit topics and
also articles go to the David Sol comedy
Facebook page facebook.com slash V so
comedy and of course follow me on
Instagram and of course follow me on
Twitter Instagram especially they're all
trying to be geo but she got more
followers of me that [ __ ] check it out
not wear a pen you guys saw previously
too what's the plan be sexy see y'all
next time though Wednesdays and Sundays
love me oh and check me out on vessel if
you want to see my videos buy these
earlier vessel vessel vessel vessel
Spencer
that's what's up that's probably because
you see a little error that's probably
because you see at least you [ __ ]
[ __ ] after you haven't heard of this
story
it's probably